foreign
[Music]
hi my name is Karen Mega of the
University of California Santa Cruz at
The genomics Institute and I'm also the
co-lead of the telomere to telomere
Consortium and today I'd like to share
with you new insights in genome biology
and structure that we're learning from
our telomer to telomere chromosome
assemblies
now as we all know the human reference
genome has been foundational for genomic
research since its release over two
decades ago we've made tremendous
progress and almost had a genome
Revolution where this particular
reference genome is centrally positioned
in in front of all of our basic science
clinical genetics as well as now our
studies of population genetics or how we
vary between individuals in our
population and our genomes sampled
throughout our bodies however a common
trend of understanding our reference
genome is that even though we've been
really good at generating lots and lots
and lots of human genomes
um most if not all of the human genomes
we produce so far are incomplete um so
there's a real need to complete a human
genome now many of you may think oh but
wait we had a celebration many years ago
about the finished Human Genome
um in fact we had the release back in
2003 but that focused exclusively on the
EU chromatic regions and the highly
repetitive heterochromatic regions such
as the human centromeres entire
acrocentric short arms which can
represent tens of megabases of sequence
telomere sub telomeres in large regions
of segmental duplication were
intentionally excluded and I want to use
a slide to just emphasize how important
these particular regions are to our
understanding of genome biology and
function it's probably very clear to
most of the audience that the Central
America regions are important for
contributing to also chromosome cohesion
and regulating chromosome segregation
during mitosis and meiosis
um the ribosomal rdnas which have been
missing from our reference genome are
critically important for Life as we know
it is they are important bringing
together amino acids to form particular
proteins and we understand that these
regions of the genome have very unique
spatial organization chromatin
organization and these are all parts of
our genome that have been not yet
explored and the large unresolved intra
and inter-segmental duplications to be
involved in genome instability and the
expansion and contraction of Gene
families
so overall I really want to emphasize
that what we're missing by having an
incomplete genome is interesting and
important biology and we haven't studied
it in the past simply because our Maps
were incomplete
so this is a fundamental problem and
it's a problem that's being addressed by
the telomere to telomere Consortium
um this is being co-led by Adam Philippi
at NIH and myself and essentially the
goal of this Consortium is to organize
the International Community with One
Singular goal to complete the human
reference genome or complete a reference
Genome of a human genome
and the sunlight that we're using is an
effectively haploid genome I want to
share what that means with the audience
to make sure that you understand it's
not a normal
um normal genome in the sense that we're
using the complete hydrophone mole this
is a cell line that's derived from an
early fertilization accident where we
have a complete loss of maternal
chromosomes either before or after
fertilization and then after the entry
of the paternal genome you have a
duplication and so you have the normal
karyotype in the sense of having 46
chromosomes however if you were to think
about it like the image that I'm showing
you with the red chromosome you might
have a tandem repeat which has 20 copies
on the maternal side and a paternal side
which is the blue copy which only has
10. and that's really complicated to try
to sort and assign those particular
repeats however if you have a duplicated
copy now you have the exact number of
repeats on either side and that really
simplifies the assembly problem
now all of our reference data that we've
been creating we have a multi-platform
approach which is really emphasizing
these long read platforms and all of
this is completely open for public use
and available on our GitHub
so the challenge here for our Consortium
was how to do proper repeat assembly and
we're all familiar with the idea of the
short read data is very difficult
um to actually assemble across these
highly repetitive regions here I'm
showing you an example of a 200 000 base
pair can
um 200
000 base pair array of tandem repeats
and if you had short read data you might
have many exact copies within this
repetitive region which could map
equally therefore there are insufficient
link to fully span these unique markers
that would inform their linear ordering
and as a result we have collapsed
assemblies and that's what we've been
dealing with with many years
now we've had a number of long read
Technologies appear on the scene one in
particular that our Consortium started
with was the celebration of these Ultra
long reads these are off the Oxford
nanopore platform where you're able to
have reads that are common in the arena
of 100 kilobases plus and extending all
the way up into megabase space so this
has been tremendous in the idea of
traversing gaps in the genome as
previously shown by Jane at all and
nature biotech back in 2018 as well as
making kind of a targeted completion of
human centromeres as my team showed back
in 2018 for the wise engineer and it was
really these two marker papers that
inspired us to move forward with the tdt
Consortium
and so here you can imagine that if you
have that same example of a 200 000 base
pair tandem repeat and you have an ultra
long sequence perhaps you can begin to
span this entire region completely
and then derive the consensus of this
entire region based on the Spanish
repeats
to our attitude
had a profound difference on how we're
doing repeat assembly is the PAC bio
High Fidelity or Hi-Fi data sets in this
case you don't benefit from the same
lead read Link in this case you're
looking at more of a 20 KB read however
the each read has a singer-like quality
where you're looking at q30 and the way
that they achieve that is by actually
doing multiple passes of a single
template of molecules I'm showing you
here in a figure
um that was taken from the Wagoner at
all at nature biotech 2019 and you have
many error-prone subroots but if you
take this circular consensus you're able
to derive a very high quality read and
the point here is that this 200 000 base
pair tandem repeat that I've been
talking about is not a perfect identical
copy there's lots of these smaller
perturbations or micro heterogeneity
that can differentiate one repeat copy
from the other and without high quality
sequence you really can't confidently
align but once you do have extremely
high quality like the Hi-Fi platform you
can begin to localize your reads
confidently to these unique markers in a
symbol across
and so our team in particular giving
credit to Sergey Nook from Adam
phillippe's group had been working on
high canoe and in this case what you're
able to do is even further improve these
already high quality reads what I'm
showing you here for example is you can
do homopolymer compression where runs of
atcs and G's can be compressed into a
single nucleotide to avoid some of the
common sequencing errors you can also do
overlap error correction if you find a
single nucleotide difference that's not
shared with any other read and ignore
some common endos in the tandem repeats
and mainly what I'm wanting you to get
from the slide is that you can begin to
improve these already Stellar reads
closer and closer and closer to a
hundred percent accurate
and this is really important when we
start thinking about centromeric regions
where we have these long chains of
tandem repeats or satellite dnas that
are often found from millions of bases
and what we're finding is if you were to
look at self-similarity of these
centromeric regions you're really able
to capture
um the heterogeneity and assemble across
without doing some multi-mapping or
mapping to other parts of the array
inappropriately one should get closer
and closer to this final polish stage at
the high five as I'm showing you here
for the self-similarity of 99.999 and so
this is exactly what was shown by the
high canoe paper earlier on where once
you begin to improve the quality of even
these Hi-Fi reads we were able to see
entire centromeric regions then being
assembled and here I'm showing you from
chromosome 19 across five megabases of
repeats
so this is the genome assembly when I
started my talk back in 2001 each one of
the oscillations between gray and black
these are breaks in the contig so you
can see this the highly fragmented
genome
um with many gaps that are still there
and now when we're looking at genome
assembly based on our Ultra long data
we're finding that entire chromosome
arms are contained in a single contig
and often we are only breaking at these
very highly repetitive centromeric
regions
and we found that both Hi-Fi and ont or
Oxford nanopore and Ultra long
assemblies are highly complementary in
the sense that we were finding entire
arms being assembled by both
Technologies but in certain cases
different chromosomes were better
performing in one versus the other
and so it's at that point that we
decided to host a workshop
um it was a finishing Workshop that was
over a hundred people joined and we
broke into subgroups and the goal here
was to work on finishing the genome
through genome assembly focusing work on
acrocentric short arms centromyric
satellite segmental duplications
epigenetic profiles transposable
elements and reference variants so we
have all of these very big and focused
workers working groups that have taken
on this challenge to finish the genome
so first
um I'd like to go ahead and credit
Sergey Nook once again who was one of
the Pioneers in some of the early change
for us of What's led to this huge
development of the release of
telomerated telomer chromosomes
essentially we took a step back and we
utilized some of the technology from
high canoe and the idea that we knew
that we could improve the already high
quality Hi-Fi reads and we could use
this information to construct a string
graph of long perfect overlaps and then
we could use the ultra long nanopore
reads to really support the resolution
of these harder tangles
what I'm showing you here is kind of all
of these string graphs broken into their
chromosome assignments and I hope you
can appreciate that each one represents
kind of a an end-to-end representation
of a single chromosome on in
implementing this new conservative
string graph method that was designed by
Sergey Nook we actually had candidates
for tdt predictions for chromosome 11
I'm indicating right away
um that came out of of our early effort
we had some clear challenges before us
these are the rdnas that I'm trying
um
to illustrate here with the the dotted
boxes where we still had links that were
being formed across the exact identical
regions that were shared across all of
the acrocentric regions and what we're
calling the distal Junction regions as
well as these long contact links
describing a duplication event that took
place in the human satellite array on
chromosome 9. but apart from that we did
not observe any other inter-chromosomal
links to this assembly and had a
wonderful place to start
and this is just telling the audience of
course that this is still a work in
progress our team has been very much
focused on completing the rdna
assemblies but looking at the graphs
themselves I would like everyone to
appreciate that the rdnas actually have
sufficient variance to be assigned in a
chromosome specific way that where we're
finding these inter-chromosomal
Junctions is really at the level of the
distal Junction or these shared regions
outside of the rdna
so the next step for our team was to try
to test how accurate these assemblies
are both at the structural level and at
the base level and so to do this we had
to realign all of our data sets to show
that we had consistencies in coverage
and also base
um base level accuracy and we did this
using two tools this is winnow map
um where I'm listing the two
Publications by janetah at the bottom
for folks who are listening to my talk
to go back and review and reference and
also something called marker assisted
mapping that we introduced in our
telomer to telomere X paper that came
out last year in nature and essentially
in the marker assisted mapping step
you're identifying all of the sites in
the genome that have a single copy
marker and you're using these markers to
help filter out reads that span unique
regions
so in doing this we were able to
accurately align and perform variant
calling across the genome so I'm sharing
this page to give or slide to give folks
the feeling of this equal coverage or
even coverage that we're observing
across however on the centromeric
regions or the highly satellite regions
we're still posing a challenge where we
were not seen completely equal even and
nice coverage across so this was really
passed off to our centromeric satellite
working group where we had a number of
really important tools that we onboarded
to ensure that these assemblies were
corrected where they needed to be and
flagged for errors and this is credited
tandem tools um which I'm showing here
reflectative errors and then go through
and correct on chromosome 10 as well as
doing targeted reassembly using
orthogonal data sets like Ultra long and
this is utilizing technology called
centrifly where we're able to re
reassemble using the ultra long reads
and show that there is consistency
between the high five predictions and
the ultralone predictions
additionally we would look at copy
number variation both
um looking directly at the Hi-Fi and
alumina PCR free based data to show that
the array links were where we expected
them in terms of length and copy number
and variant frequency and we also teamed
up with Jennifer curtin's team to
demonstrate that we could use digital
droplet PCR to directly Target and
assess some of these instrument arrays
and chm13
overall we issued a complete sequence of
the human genome with an asterisk there
because we are still planning to release
the rdna or data sets in the near future
but this particular assembly that we've
released has 23 chromosomes uh this was
a an XX cell line so we had no y but
there are zero unlocalized zero unplaced
contigs in this and overall we've
introduced 100 to 190 megabases of new
sequences that were currently not
present in hg38
all of our data our blog posts and
description of these particular sites
are present on our GitHub page through
our tdt Consortium and we encourage the
use and the open and public use of these
data
so some of the big takeaways is that we
now have entire acrocentric short arms
that we can now study that have never
been studied before
um this is representing over 90
megabases of newly introduced sequences
where we now have new satellite dnas our
dnas
um flanking these particular gaps that
we've we're planning to update with the
rdas themselves segmental duplications
and over and hundreds of new candidate
Gene annotations that we're including in
the new reference
just taking kind of a deeper dive into
these acrocentric short arms we're now
starting to characterize
um the satellite patterning that we're
observing in the arms and comparing it
to the literature to ensure that we're
seeing consistency
um with the fish-based methods and also
diving in even deeper to understand some
of these newly discovered sequence
features that were missing from repeat
Massacre annotation and previous
characterization
of course the largest gaps previously in
hg38 were also in centrameric regions
not only the acrocentric short arms we
knew going into the centromeric regions
were not just a series of tandoned
repeats but were kind of a mixture of
segmental duplications many of which
could contain parallelogous genes I'm
showing you here as well as an
interspersed transposable elements
and so our team's been building high
resolution maps of all of the human
pericentromeric regions and centromeric
regions as I'm showing you here
um essentially the alpha satellite which
is a 171 at Rich satellite which is
known to be present at every normal
human centromere is absolutely present
at all of the human centromeres in the
agent 13. so we've done a deep dive of
characterization of those in addition
we've been characterizing all of the
classical human satellites beta
satellites and other satellites in this
particular cell line as well
and what we're finding is a lot of
really cool stuff um for example we've
now noted the discovery of candidate
genes and coding regions that now exist
in central regions um this is once again
crediting the leadership of Mark deacons
who's been leading our Gene annotation
team at Savannah Hoyt who's been leading
some of our transposable element
annotation as well as leading proseq
where we're finding examples of Gene
bodies that exist in centronic regions
that have evidenced by prayer seek for
having polymerase read through
additionally as I mentioned before we're
doing a huge analysis of the majority of
sequences in the Central America regions
we know that they are defined by
collections of satellite dnas and arrays
and so here I'm showing you chromosome
one where we have five megabases of
alpha satellite and also 13.2 megabases
of classical human satellites and so
we're able to for the first time begin
to study arrays of satellite DNA at high
resolutions
and so in doing this we've established a
team of experts to go in and begin to
provide really clear and well-defined
annotation at these particular sites
where we can begin to study
relationships between the satellites
themselves and provide kind of addiction
for researchers going forward for how
they can begin to describe the
satellites in terms of their naming
nomenclature and organization into
repeat structures
one of the interesting things for us of
course was going into the human
satellites two and three these are less
established in the literature as the
alpha satellite are unfortunately we
were able to onboard Nick altamos who
was a leading researcher in the human
satellite Arena he had previously done a
genome characterization of these header
heterochromatic regions involving hsat 2
and hsat 3 and created subfamily
characterizations so we were able to
quickly go through and identify that yes
these predictions match prior
characterization of these sub families
and that we could begin to study some of
the homogenization patterns and repeat
structures for the first time
we've also teamed up with a number of
repeat experts to start to evaluate with
repeat modeler and de novo repeat
prediction programs
um repeats that may have been missing
from hg38 that had not been previously
described before this is work that's
largely led by Rachel O'Neill's team
from Uconn and in this case we're
discovering 208 new repeat predictions
and they map it to roughly 52 000
genomic sites and we're also finding
combinations of disposable elements or
what we're calling composite repeat
elements that are then repeated in
tandem over and over again so these
composite satellites are kind of a new
discovery for our team and we're
starting to map where they exist in the
genome and begin to characterize them as
well
this is just another slide to give the
audience a feel for these types of
Composites that we're seeing
um involving the beta satellite sst1
satellites as well as acrocentric
satellites as well so we're starting to
see this as a common Trend in some of
these unknown regions
in addition to the satellites and the
acrocentric short arms we're building
comprehensive maps of segmental
duplications we're very lucky to work
with Evan Eichler and Mitchell Vogel who
are the world's leaders I would credit
with segmental duplication biology and
genomics and in doing so we're now able
to identify new segmental duplications
as shown in red here both inter and
intraco chromosomally
and additionally to characterizing the
presence of these segmental duplications
we're able to quantify the number of
segmentally duplicated bases that we're
finding outside of hg38 and also focused
on the 30 Gene containing duplications
where we're seeing expansions and
contractions of Gene families that had
not been well characterized before
so now that we have these incredible
maps how do we use them as I suggested
in my talk title to actually study
genome biology structure and function
and so to do that perhaps we need to
start moving them into a world where we
can start to study not only the genetic
organization and structure but also the
epigenetic regulation
this is really once again a question of
how one can assign reads for example if
you had an epigenetic data set to these
highly repetitive regions and one method
of doing this is to actually anchor
these reads using High confident unique
markers or these marker assisted mapping
and that's something that's actively
performed by our team
I'd like to start off with the question
of studying methylation in these
particular regions this is something
that we kind of gained for free using
the Oxford nanopore platform and this
work was led by Ariel gershman who is
from Winston temps group at Johns
Hopkins University
essentially what it is is that when you
have nanopore data you could actually
directly probe the chemical structure of
the molecule with exquisite sensitivity
so as it's reading through there's a
signal that can be read and this allows
one to be begin to predict cpg
methylation but because the reads from
the ultra long platform are so long now
we can begin to correlate epigenetic
State over hundreds of kilobases of
sequins and anchor them confidently to
the genome and so this allows us to
build these really comprehensive
epigenetic and methylation based
profiles across telomere to telomere
chromosomes and each one of the reads as
I'm hoping you can appreciate originate
from a single cell so not only are we
able to look at these methylation
patterns in bulk we're actually able to
study the epigenetic heterogeneity
within the sample
so as you would expect there's some
basic controls to bring you up to speed
the idea that you're in a transposable
element you have an expectation to be
methylated and indeed we do find as I'm
trying to illustrate in red and increase
in cpg methylations over the
transposable elements and when you're in
a gene body although you're expected to
have methylation at the side of
transcription You're Expecting
hypomethylation or unmethylated cpgs and
as shown in blue that's what we're
observing as well
so now if you begin to go into these
regions that had not been studied before
such as the dxb4 locus which is known to
be on the long arm of chromosome X you
can then see that this particular side
is of interest to many teams because it
serves as a tandem repeat that separates
pretty large Tad domains on the X but
when you dig in further we're finding
that these repeat structures have a very
interesting oscillating pattern of being
cpg methylated and cpg unmethylated as
you can hopefully appreciate from this
red to blue to red to blue to red to
blue and it's really seems to be
structured around the organization of
the repeats themselves because once
those repeats are inverted and and gain
some Divergence we see a complete drop
off in cpg methylation that extends out
perhaps one of the most exciting
findings um at least for our team is in
turmeric working group is that we were
starting to detect these large
hypomethylated regions within each of
the Central America arrays
um this I'm showing you here has been
published for the chromosome X that
looks to be about 60 kilobases in length
but of course once we go through all of
the new established centromeric regions
we're finding this trend is is true for
all human centromeres that we find this
very um or strategic but very precise
depth that happens across the arrays
so there's a very natural question here
when you're thinking about the
centromeric regions and you see this
type of shift in methylation from cpg
methylation to going to unmethylated and
so in this question we had asked is this
actually the site where the kinetochore
is being established or where the
functional centromere takes place where
you have the Machinery come in and
actually touch um some of the genomic
sites that are enabled for proper
chromosome segregation and some key
proteins here to facilitate that are
Centric protein a as I'm showing in Red
so our team next began to ask if we
could take a different approach to look
at DNA binding proteins to begin to
layer more context into these
methylation maps and in doing so we've
teamed up with Gina caldas from
University of Berkeley who at the time
was working with Abby durenberg to go
through experiments of Cut and Run
and here I'm trying to show you that yes
indeed we identified that the dip
coincides with sites of some PA
enrichment this was a finding that was
also reported by glennis logsdon who's
um recently published a telomerated
telomer 8 paper in nature
and this hypomethylated region not only
correlates with chromosome 8 and
chromosome X as we would expect but all
of the human centromeric arrays that we
find this hypomethylated dip we in fact
find that they they Trend with these
sites of kinetochore assembly
so not only do we have now a method
established for looking at DNA binding
proteins in methylated bases but we're
also interested in looking at RNA
transcription that's happening in these
particular regions this is teaming up
with Savannah Hoyt once again from
Rachel O'Neill's group at UConn where
we've been anchoring prosecreets using
this marker assisted mapping step to
study sites of transcription throughout
the array and what we're finding is that
the majority of transcription that's
happening in centrameric regions are
primarily in the transposable elements
we find very very few reads that are
emanating from the satellite dnas
themselves
additionally we've been looking at
centromeric transcription of the genes
that are there to see if any of the
particular genes are being transcribed
and we're finding most of the expression
in the chm13 centromeric regions are
from the fshd region Gene one
pseudogenes that are involved in various
disease studies so this is something too
that we're trying to follow up on to
study the differences in the genes that
are being expressed at the terms of how
they're represented in their splice and
transcript levels
so overall of what I presented today is
a high resolution characterization of
200 megabases plus of this Human Genome
that's been missing from hg38 and what
we're finding are new repeat classes and
repeat structures and involving
inversions and homogenization and many
genes and protein binding motifs that
had not been present in our previous
assembly and by having this incredible
reference in front of us we're now able
to dive into questions of genome biology
and structure by probing DNA methylation
um looking at DNA binding protein
binding and expression profiling
we're not yet to the Finish Line
everything that I've showed you today of
course is using this effectively haploid
special line we do expect there's a
technological barrier to getting to
diploid T to T genomes is something that
we've paired up now with the hprc or the
human pan genome reference Consortium
and we're hoping to reach the production
of hundreds of PT genomes that's our
next barrier that needs to be addressed
in the future
and so in the Hope here is that these
new tdt assemblies will really
revolutionize genetics and genomics in
the sense of having a more complete
genome may lead to the discovery of new
and important clinical variants that had
been overlooked in the past
um additionally this will expand our
understanding of human sequence
variation in evolution and hopefully
I've shared with you over the epigenetic
studies this may lead to new biological
Insight of how the genome is organized
at a cellular level and how these
regions in particular contribute to our
understanding of how the cell works so
with that I'd like to end my talk this
has really been a celebration of
collaborative and open science RTD
Community is open anyone is welcome to
join and I would be very happy to take
any questions if anyone would like to
email me directly thank you